ونحييكم من جديد مرحله جديده في مسار
العلاقات التركيه المصريه يسعى من خلالها
قاده البلدين لبعث العلاقات برؤيه مختلفه
والحفاظ على المصالح المشتركه والاهم تجنب
تاثير الخلافه السياسيه العابره على مبدا
اي حسن الجوار وعدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه الطرفين بعد عشر سنوات من
القطيعه العلاقات بين القاهره وانقره مد
خطوط التعاون وفتح صفحه جديده ستكون من
بين اولويات الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان الذي
خاض معركه انتخابيه صعبه تمكن من خلالها
من البقاء في منصب رئاسه الجمهوريه بيان
لرئاسه مصريه افاد بان رئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي ونظيره التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان قرر البدء الفوري في ترفيع
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه وفي تبادل السفراء
المتحدث باسم رئاسه المصريه ذكر في بيان
ان السيسي واردوغان اكد خلال اتصال هاتفي
على عمق الروابط التاريخيه التي تربط
البلدين والشعبين تقارب سيكون على اساس
دعم اواصر الاخوه والتعاون بين الجانبين
في العديد من المجالات وفقع ما ذكر
المتحدث باسم رئاسه المصريه ترفيع
العلاقات ياتي بعد زياره او زيارات
ومباحثات بين مسؤوليه البلدين حيث زار
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري انقره في
ابريل الماضي تلبيه لدعوه نظيره التركي
مولود جاويش اوغلو الزياره جاءت استكمالا
للمباحثات التي اجريت خلال زياره وزير
الخارجيه التركي الى القاهره في مارس
الماضيه التي تمحورت حول سبل تعزيز
العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين ونناقش هذا
الموضوع متابعينا مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
الدكتور بشير عبد الفتاح الباحث في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
اهلا بك ومن اسطنبول دكتور مهند حافظ
اوغلو الاكاديمي والباحثه السياسي اهلا
بكم ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من
القاهره معك دكتور بشير ولندخل مباشره في
جوهر الموضوع دون مقدمات عقد من القطيعه
بين البلدين تركيا كانت تعتبر مصر او فتره
العشر سنوات انقلابا كانت تسميه هكذا ومصر
من جهتها كانت تعتبر بان تركيا عدو لدود
خاصه بعد استقبالها للاخوان وحمايتهم لهم
على اي مبدا ستعود هذه العلاقات وسيعود
السفراء هل بمبدا النسيان مقابل فتح صفحه
جديده مثلا وكيف
تحيه لكريم ولضيفك الكريم ولكل مشاهدي
قناه العربيه في كل مكان
يمكن القول ان العلاقات التركيه المصريه
منذ العام 2013 خضعت لمستويين من التقويم
المستوى الرسمي والمستوى الدعائي او
الاعلامي على المستوى الرسمي كانت مصر ترى
في تركيا انها تتبنى سياسات عدائيه او غير
وديه حيال الدوله المصريه ولم ولا يمكن
القول بان البلدين قد انحضرتا الى مستوى
العداء او الصدام هذه السياسات العدائيه
كانت في ملف الاخوان المسلمين وتوفير
تركيا منصات اعلاميه وسياسيه واحتضان
قيادات وتوفير ملذات امنه في ليبيا ايضا
كان هناك سياسات عدائيه من قبل تركيا حيال
المصالح المصريه هناك تتمثل فيه الزق
بالمرتزقه والاسلحه وعسكره الازمه الليبيه
بطريقه او باخرى في شرق المتوسط اتباع
سياسه البوارج البحريه الامتثال للقانون
الدولي في ترسيم الحدود البحريه
وتوزيع الثروات الطبيعيه في سوريا والعراق
العسكره التدخل العسكري في الدولتين
واحتلال اراضي وسياسات المائيه العدوانيه
حيال البلدين وبالتالي كانت سياسات عدائيه
على مستوى الاعلام كان هناك انفلات اعلامي
واضح وصف الامر على انه عداء وصدام حتى ان
حديث الحرب كان يذاع في ذلك الوقت والبعض
يتحدث عن احتمالات مواجهه عسكريه في ليبيا
واشياء من هذا القبيل خصوصا بعد ما اشاع
عن دور تركي في مساله السد الاثيوبي الذي
يهدد الامن المائي المصري لكن العلاقات
المصريه التركيه لها جذور راسخه الدولتان
مسلمتاني سنيتان مهمتان في اقليم الشرق
الاوسط
وامكانات التنسيق والتفاهم بينهما لخدمه
الاقليم وخدمه مصالحهم الاستراتيجيه قائمه
بدليل ان الدولتين بعدما عرف ان الجفاء
والسياسات العدائيه تركيا حياله مصر هي
مكلفه للغايه بالنسبه للدوله المصريه
التركيه كما انها تعطل ايضا المصالح
الاستراتيجيه المصريه سارعت تركيا لمد
جسور التفاهم مع القاهره والود مع القاهره
وصلنا الى نقطه مفصليه مهمه منذ العام
2021 وحتى اليوم مفاوضات استكشافيه ثم
اتصال بين الرؤساء ولقاء الرؤساء في
الدوحه وصولا الى الاعلام بالامس عن ترفيع
العلاقات الى مستوى السفراء ليس معنى ذلك
ان القضايا الخلفيه تم حلاتها وانما نحن
نتقارب لايجاد ارضيه للحوار والتفاؤل
سنعود للقضايا الخلافيه ولكن حضرتك تقول
بان تركيا سارعت للمصالحه مع القاهره
دكتور مهند هل المصلحه او المنتفع الكبير
من هذا التقارب هي تركيا وبالتالي الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان تنازل او تراجع عما كان
يتحدث به بخصوص مصر بخصوص لانه نحن لا
نتحدث عن بلدين فقط نحن نتحدث عن خصوم بين
شخصين بين قائدين بين رئيسين وبالتالي هل
التنازل او التراجع اتى من تركيا بالاساس
للتقارب
وجميع المشاهدين والضيف الكريم يعني اذا
كانت القياده المصريه تتبنى نفس المفردات
او الكلمات او هذا الخطاب الذي يقوله ضيفك
من القاهره فاننا امام مشكله حقيقيه هذه
المفترضه المفردات وهذا الاسلوب الذي
وكانه
متعالي على تركيا يقول لك تحركات عدوانيه
تعسكرت ليبيا وعرنا انه انا تركيا لولا
تركيا لكانت ليبيا كلها غارقه في الدماء
تركيا من اجبرت كل اللاعبين الفاعلين في
الملف الليبي على الذهاب نحو الديمقراطيه
والتوقف عند تحرك العسكري هذا الخطاب انا
لا اظن ان القياده في مصر تتبنى هذا
الخطاب والا لن نكون هناك صفحه جديده يعني
كل ما جرى ما بين وزراء ما بين تركيا ومصر
من هذه الزيارات ما هو الا تمهيد اولي
ريثما تتبلور وتتكشكل ارضيه حقيقيه صلبه
النهوض والذهاب الى الامام نحو علاقات
وفتح صفحه جديده وبناء عليه العلاقات
التركيه المصريه ليست مرتبطه فقط
بالقاهره
وانقره مرتبطه كذلك بالتحرك القاهره مع
طهران متحركه
بمحاوله القاهره فرض ان الملف الليبي هو
الملف الاساسي الذي يجب على تركيا ان تخرج
وتوما لطالما سمعنا هذه التعابير من ان
تركيا يجب ان تخرج من ليبيا علما انها قد
وقعت اتفاقا شرعيا وسجل لدى الامم المتحده
فضلا عن الدعوات التي نسمعها من الجامعه
العربيه يعني خلينا ندخل في هذه التفاصيل
طالما دخلتم لليبيا والغاز المتوسط دكتور
مهند حضرتك لما تتحدث على الملف الليبي
بهذا الملف شائك لانه تركيا لما صلحت صلحت
حكومه طرابلس مما اعتبرت مصر بانه هناك
عسكره داخل الليبي لان مصر من جهتها قريبه
او تتعاون او تؤمن بشرعيه الجيش الليبي
بالتاريخ لفحفتر فهذا شرخ كبير بين
الجانبين دكتور بشير كيف سيحل مثلا هكذا
اسمحي لي استاذه ريم في البدايه ان اعلق
سريعا على ما اشار اليه الضيف التركي
بانني بمساله تمثيل الدوله المصريه انا
هنا في هذا المنبر الاعلامي المحترم انا
لا امثل سوى نفسي كمراقب وباحث ولا امثل
مؤسسه الاهرام ولا الدوله المصريه لاني لا
اتقلد منصب رسميا في الدوله المصريه ومن
ثم يعني مساله ان الدوله تفكر بهذا الشيء
او ذاك يعني هذا كلام بعيد عن الواقع فيما
يتعلق بالمساله الليبيه بالفعل تركيا في
عهد الرئيس اردوغان تميل الى عسكره
السياسه الخارجيه معروف في ابجديات علم
العلاقات الدوليه ان السياسه الخارجيه لها
اربع اذرع ذراع دبلوماسي ذراع اقتصادي
ذراع عسكري وذراع ثقافي الرئيس اردوغان
كان يغلب الذراع العسكري الحال في العراق
واضح الحال في سوريا واضح الحال في ليبيا
كان واضحا في ليبيا تمثل فيه اولا الزج
بالاسلحه الى فصائل متقاتله وفصائل بعينها
داخل ليبيا الزجه بالمرتزقه داخل ليبيا
ايضا تعطيل المسار السياسي مصر كانت تدعم
دائما المؤسسات الشرعيه وحده الدوله
الليبيه
الحفاظ على وحده التراث الليبي الجيش
الوطني
اتفاعل مع حضرتك دكتور بشير فيما حضرتك
تعتبره تعطيل المسار السياسي دكتور مهند
يقول بالعكس بان تركيا هي التي طرحت موضوع
التقارب اللي بهكذا تتحدد دكتور مهند صحيح
طبعا لان تركيا عندما دعمت حكومه طرابلس
بالسلاح وبالقوه العسكريه وذلك بسبب الحرب
العسكريه على طرابلس يعني هي لم هي مجرد
رده فعل لما جرى من محاوله انتزاع الشرعيه
من طرابلس هذا امر جلي وواضح وبناء عليه
لا يمكن ان نقول بان تركيا تريد ان تعسكر
ان تؤيد او تاتي مرتزقه
هذا التوصيف ولكن السؤال الذي يبقى كيف
سيحل هكذا خلاف هل يمكن لحكومه اردوغان
انت تراجع عما اسماه ضيفي عسكره داخل
الليبي
هذا الامر تركيا لن تخرج من ليبيا الا
بطلب من الحكومه الليبيه
ولن تتراجع في هذا الملف بمعنى انها سوف
تنسحب من الساحه الليبيه
مرغمه وبقدونس طلب شرعي من الحكومه
الليبيه كلنا يعلم ان هناك انتخابات في
يناير المقبل في ليبيا بعد اجتماع سته
زائد سته بناء عليه الملف الليبي تركيا هي
صمام الامان فيه والى ان تستقر الامور
ميدانيا عسكريا سياسيا
اقتصاديا في ليبيا لا يمكن الحديث عن خروج
تركيا من ليبيا هذا اظن ان القاهره عليها
ان تتفاهمها او تتفاهموا
ملف ملف اصعب منه وهو ملف شرق المتوسط شرق
المتوسط سناتي الى ان مكاننا الوقت مثلا
ولكن دكتور ساعود لك دكتور بشير ضيف يقول
بانه القاهره يجب ان تتفهم ذلك هل يمكن ان
تتفاهم بحسب قراءه حضرتك القاهره هذه
الحسابات التركيه
طبعا هذا الكلام لا يلزم الا صاحبه نحن لا
نتلقى اوامر او تعليمات من احد نتفهم
اولاد نتفهم نحن لدينا رؤيتنا الواضحه
والمستقله لما يدور في الشان الليبي تركيا
راهنت على فصيل وفئه بعينها في داخل ليبيا
وهي فئه ليست شرعيه لان هناك انقسام في
الداخل الليبي تركيا اختارت الفصيل الذي
يخدم مصالحها وخياراتها داخل ليبيا بدليل
انها ابرمت مذكرات تفاهم مع الحكومه
الليبيه في 2019 في مواضيع خطيره للغايه
كترسيم الحدود البحريه واستغلال منشات
نفطيه واشياء من هذا القبيل بينما الحكومه
لم تكن مخوله لابرام هذه المذكرات
التفاهميه ولذلك لم تعتمد ولم يعترف بها
البرلمان مساله ان تحدد انت شرعيه في
التدخل من عدمه هذا جرى ايضا في سوريا
والعراق سوريا والعراق تقدمت بشكاوى للامم
المتحده رافضتين التدخل العسكري التركي في
كل منهما والتموضع العسكري التركي خلال
الاراضي هذا الشيء حدث في ليبيا دكتور
بشير
هناك نقاط اخرى كذلك نقاط خلافيه مثلا
ترسيم الحدود البحريه
فيما تركيا
ابرمت معاهده او اتفاقيه مع حكومه الوفاق
وقتها في ليبيا على ترسيم الحدود البحريه
ردت عليها مصر واليونان بترسيم معاهده
كذلك في المقابل وبترسيم حدود بحريه هل
هذا التقارب ورفع مستوى التمثيل
الدبلوماسي بين الجانبين يمكن ان يعيد
الموضوع ويطرح من جديد ونجد اتفاق بين
الطرفين سابدا بالدكتور مهند
طبعا في السياسه لا مستحيل ولكن الاراده
الحقيقيه للتغيير والنظر بواقعيه منطقيه
للملفات يعني نتحدث عن شرق المتوسط هناك
اكثر من ملف ترسيم الحدود البحريه ملف
القبرصي منتدى غاز شرق المتوسط والذي كانت
مصر متزاعيمه له ضريبه بالجغرافيا التركيه
الواسعه عرض الحائط وكان تركيا
الا اميال معينه للسياحه والسباحه اذا لم
يكن هناك اراده حقيقيه وجاده بالفعل الى
تقارب ما بين هذه الدولتين المهمتين في
هذا الوقت الحساس وصعب دوليا واقليميا
فاننا ندخل في اشكال عدم التقدم السياسه
كل في كل ما هو في السياسه ممكن ان كانت
هناك اراده حقيقيه بمعنى الدكتور
متوسط كيف لتركيا ان تطالب بمثل هكذا
تسويات وهي يقول البعض التفت مثلا على
موضوع الاخوان مصر طلبتها بقائمه لمطلوبين
لمحكومين ولكن تركيا يقول البعض بانها
التفت على هذه الحلول ومكانته من المغادره
هناك مصادر تقول حتى بانها مكانتهم من
التمويل وبالتالي دكتور بشير هل يمكن ان
تتجاوز القاهره هذا الملف
بالطبع يا استاذه ريم الخطوه التي حدثت في
التقارب على مستوى التمثيل الدبلوماسي
خطوه مهمه لان كل القضايا الخلافيه
الاربعه التي اشرت اليها ليبيا وشرق
المتوسط وسوريا والعراق والاخوان لا يمكن
ان تحل الا من خوال من خلال حوار ومفاوضات
عبر اللجان فنيه متخصصه لكن فيما يخص شرق
المتوسط نحن لم نتجاهل تركيا ولم نستبعد
تركيا بالمناسبه لا مشكله حقيقيه بين مصر
وتركيا فيما يخص ترسيم الحدود البحريه
وتعيين المناطق الاقتصاديه الخالصه بشرق
المتوسط مشاكل تركيا مع قبرص مع اليونان
وليست مع مصر حتى منتدى غاز شرق المتوسط
الذي تحول الان الى منظمه غاز شرق المتوسط
مصر اعلنت منذ تاسيسه انه مفتوح امام
الجميع وشروط عضويه الدوله في ان تحترم
القانون الدولي وقواعد العلاقات الدوليه
في ترسيم الحدود البحريه واستغلال الثروات
الطبيعيه حتى الان تركيا لم تلتزم تركيا
البحريه بموجب الاتفاقيه العامه لقانون
البحار عام 1982 وبالتالي الكره في الملعب
التركي على التركي ان تلتزم
عن استراتيجيه العسكريه في شرق المتوسط
وضحت الفكره اكيد بان هناك تفاصيل تفاصيل
ستبحث وكما يقال الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل
سنعود لهذا الموضوع اكثر من مره لمناقشته
وشكركم جزيل الشكر على الحضور من القاهره
الدكتور بشير عبد الفتاح الباحث في مركز
الاهرام للدراسه السياسيه ومن اسطنبول
الدكتور محمد حافظ والباحثه السياسي شكرا
لكم
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع فاصل ونناقش من بعضه
قاصدين منها ان الخدمات تمشي لاهل بينها
طرفي الصراع السوداني خمسه ايام من الهدنه
هل ستنجح مساء الوصول الى وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار رغم الانتهاكات المتواصله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات